citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to go to War World War II Justice
Society Justice League World War II
which is it I don't know but I'm excited
have you seen this too I have not Coy I
feel like every so often there's an
entire surge of new people that are like
why are they re-watching these and I
gotta say hey not it's a First Time
Warner never seen him we're approaching
like 30 of these I know it's trippy man
pretty exciting we're powering through a
journey together we almost like we've
been to war war videos of the DC
Universe at least a couple times we've
seen a lot of continuities a lot of
Hawkman not talking today that might
change maybe he'll speak a little bit
more than Black Bolt we'll find out
leave in the comments below what you
want us to watch next we have begun our
tomorrow verse Journey also always
remember to hit that notification Bell
to find out when we got more of these
and like subscribe share this with your
friends so we can keep making more of
these because that's how it works and we
also want to thank prepper for editing
the reaction because without them it's a
lot of us staring at a screen and that's
not nearly as fun or is it thank you
prepper for making us look good without
further Ado I want to remind you to also
become a patron too then you can watch
this entire experience front to back
beginning to end with our resting faces
we're very very pensive but engaged
that's how we rest and watch that's
obviously everybody knows uh I think
that's gonna do it because we've we've
been to wakan we've had a bat verse
shirt and now we go to war in three two
[Applause]
Mr President already we have to act now
it's kind of like driving yeah through
the city
they've taken control of most of Europe
and Russia it's an invasion he's been
searching for ancient artifacts of
course you'll mean magical artifacts
Auto Maniac unless of course he's right
I mean both can be true yes
let me introduce you to the team rex
Tyler known as our man
now he's developed a chemical called
meraklow to enhance speed strength
everything an hour at a time damn
Lance a bit of a fire brain with Sonic
sound abilities that have gotten her
shunned by her community she's just
fully World War II Black Canary
obtaining his powers of speed Jay
Garrick has been a full-time crime
fighter Carter Hall an ancient Egyptian
in a modern Egyptian's body
claims this is his uh fourth
reincarnation
who will lead this Motley Crew I think
I've got someone in mind
yes I thought that was Steve Trevor what
do you say Mr President are you ready to
end this war
yes I love it love the old school Vibes
I like when they commit to a choice um
at Bomer oh yeah like commitment is so
key when you're making something like
this it is society that makes more sense
for World War II but I wasn't certain I
don't want to be wrong so I went with
both it makes sense it's Society
gets to know societies versus leagues
everything that's just it's a simple job
somebody's got to do it makes more sense
canonically but then again Wonder Woman
being part of the Justice it's fine it's
fine
according to the trajectory of the sun
we should have the max amount of light
if we set the blanket
here get a little shade it's gonna be a
hot damn Metropolis oh
[Music]
do you think it might rain I can grab an
umbrella just in case just
you wanted to get out of town away from
my other job what do you want from me is
this just a fling because no no Iris
it's okay if it is but I'm not
interested oh I love you the best way to
keep you safe is by making sure no one
finds out if you really believe that
then break up with me
oh I'll make it up to you tomorrow a
hundred sandwiches
but it is illogical
not if you're Superman
[Music]
tickle them
is he immune to tickling
cool shot nice oh geez this is well
animated I'm enjoying the POV stuff help
with the tentacles
yes
oh
accelerating projectiles
oh damn it oh
[Music]
recalibration success at 99 it's gonna
be so annoying to fight this guy yeah
never tell me the odds
[Music]
the speed force
that Dr Fate yeah how and why I don't
yet know cool so you end up back in
World War II
[Music]
would not want to fight her nope oh yeah
damn they made her especially fast yeah
that's awesome
ricochet
bouncing dudes off the fights in this is
awesome yeah consistently
oh
yeah
geez this must have come out after
Wonder Woman yeah yeah the movie there's
a lot of mirroring I keep expecting to
hear the whole thing yeah right my
chunky XL where are you
ah right on time
kind of crazy
did president Roosevelt send you what's
happening keep an eye on
whatever this is
am I dead
this is the afterlife
Nazis
yep
now's your chance Barry Bonk bunk
oh dang
awesome
dang that was amazing speed slapping
Nazi I'm from the future it's not
impossible I mean with the speed force
we got is it Tom Hardy up there don't
show his face yeah
Steve
Steve yeah yeah ah you
can't you hurt States oh no I really
just say
trajectory the velocity hawkman's
wingspan he won't make it no damn
cheese good povs in this movie yeah the
lockout shots and povs are amazing
now back into the speed force
what if the oxygen is different I wonder
why he's having trouble breathing
oh there you go
teamwork boy I see you picked up another
Playmate it seems I misjudged you thank
you seems that I also look past your
very similar costume to our own flag
this this gentleman with the similar
symbol on his chest
hourman you and J with me on the ground
Carter you and Dinah take the sky and I
can do nothing if
I've been that movie
oh yeah
[Music]
love the teamwork little teamwork Beats
nice awesome that's great
[Music]
oh no not the pawn shops not the bond
intro
Oh I thought I said shiza for a second
[__]
it's the Battle Cry
Future Boy this is Shakespeare a war
correspondent
do I know you this is Howard Stark also
Billy Shakespeare yeah Billy shakes the
real sugar I can't hold this in anymore
will you marry me
attempt Trevor oh oh
ouch he proposes every day and every day
she says no didn't take you for a
stalker
[Music]
you've got a new Mission we can't decode
the Intel the Germans are looking for a
new artifact they're saying it's a game
changer oh no a man with mystical
abilities they pulled him out of their
camps and stuck him in a securely
guarded Castle in Bavaria they say he
can break any code problem is he's
insane what are we gonna do about him he
should stick with us for research ah I'm
really curious how if this is part of
that tomorrow verse how this all ties in
with like flash not knowing the Justice
League obviously Batman was separate and
Superman was separate maybe we'll
culminate in a big old League finally
was that the voice of the same Superman
that's a good question yeah I feel like
but I'm not 100 okay
wow Castle Wolfenstein let's move out
the slide every time
nice dude nice
if this goes Haywire blame The New Guy
sharing the speed force and all that is
interesting with time travel
no
throw that plate at him or the whole
table or yeah he said she would come
this is yours
supposed to give this to you who's who
sent you you have to make sure it never
happens
oh
no oh no Shakespeare
Ah
that's why I look familiar to flash yeah
and if the curl is these straight lines
I didn't recognize them the mustache
clever it's the same actor Coy oh
clearly the voice actor that I've been
not hearing this all time
hey what did they do to you no it's
it's
can oof I know him from a previous life
well make him snap out of it we're not
equipped to handle it they're all
dead oh we need your help my friend
can you translate this
oh
wow
it's Clark ah
it's Clark Kent interesting you're
Superman it's me flash how did you get
here did you follow me through that time
work is this a rescue why do you have a
mustache
you're one of the most selfless people I
know I don't know you in my time on this
planet I learned you look out for
yourself and journalism in my time
something's different what about your
parents Martha and Jonathan Kent died in
an accident when I was three years old I
was sent to an orphanage oh dang what do
they teach you there I'm not in the past
this isn't a different time whoa this is
a different earth oh no crises on more
Earths there's so many crises and so
many Earths
that makes more sense for continuity
Yeah by not making sense for continuity
yep
coordinates
no he's not ready yet just
know what it means huh you arguing about
Superman for please do you know a way
for me to get back home back to my
universe but this would be Earth One the
real Earth
you may return but you have another task
ahead of you and a lesson human
no I won't tell him about the league
regenerate to maybe three ships above us
do they know we're here we're about to
find out since the Justice society's
official submarine crew
that just thinks of battleships
no
flooding ugh
nice man Jenner the Justice Society we
we have to surface is there any way to
restart the engines
you have an extra 20 batteries lying
around I got a couple flashes
there she is what now no subs took
batteries yeah
oh yeah
sweet well I'll be
I'm learning so many new things I could
do with my power I'm a brand new Flash
lock this behind me and flood the tube
torpedo woman you are just so beautiful
when you're about to kick some Nazi tail
you know there is a captain on board let
me make an honest Amazon
come on come on that was a good one both
of you climbing the tube he's good at
proposing
go
oh bad
cool nice
it's raining depth charges
D3 D4
you suck my battles good job Wonder
Woman
oh
no who These Guys these related to
Brainiac somehow they've they got that
vibe
they got red eyes can't trusted pull
over
what has happened
oh dang maybe they can be trusted with
their red eyes so is Atlantis in the
Bermuda Triangle that would make sense
that's why all those disappearances
wow cool this is so like sprawling it's
exciting because I don't know any of
this cannon so it's like all new yeah
I'm loving this I'm Arthur ruler of
Atlantis in all of the oceans of this
world why should I care about the
Affairs of those above because these
Nazis will not stop until the whole
world is theirs above and below as above
I think you speak true daughter of a
politer I will help you there is
something I have that might turn the
tide in your favor ah the tide the tide
it's an ocean pun he's got puns the king
of Atlantis made a pun
yes I see nothing quite ah damn it
betrayal why Aquaman why Aqua Nazi
plenty and Magic is quite powerful these
they're trying to escape
Heil Hitler
oh no Aqua Nazi a
storm destroyed my ship and the
atlanteans saved me little
know that my particular talents would
grant me control of their King
oh you set us up the war is all but over
and you have lost enjoy the Solitude of
this prison oh it's time to show those
above what true power looks like should
make his mustache shadow just a little
more bring it in a little bit I mean he
does look like the Aryan he is pretty
much the ideal blonde blue eyes should
have known although if we can somehow
combine our energy we might regain full
power how will that bypass magic physics
are Universal Diana when I was younger I
could vibrate between molecules
seriously you can do that what the heck
have I been doing all these years I love
the back and forth teaching each other
how to flash
[Music]
foreign
that was fantastic that was beautiful
physical comedy one of the guards said
the king Aqua Man is headed down to the
trench he's going to unlock some sort of
cage what's in the cage a spin-off movie
it would have been a Black Manta movie
we would have liked it yeah they're also
committed to this sort of Classic
Hollywood lighting yeah you know very
much of the era lighting yeah that like
three-point like nose Loop kind of thing
talking to the Shell who knows what
might happen what does this do
plantian pressure
use your Trident to focus your call
unlock the gate bring the creatures seal
our Victory locked Gates
[Music]
sweet
oh yeah
come on flash wake him up
not so special without your suit yeah
crappy name or
I'm strong
don't worry
get your fill of violence
jeez
[Music]
wake up
let's go
no
something is wrong
oh they got a power player
[Music]
oh Legends of the Hidden Temple
yes it's the Elder gods are angry God
no
atlanteans always invading beaches
wow
we got hover tanks
how about a real fight
how's that for some sonar
got a perfect view from the balcony hon
let's watch the end of the world join
the Army and fight Nazis fall in love
with an Amazonian princess and end up in
an atlantian tank taking on bad guys
Steve Trevor never complained about
being bored again
it was all in the pamphlet man you knew
what you were signing up for they warned
you
yeah it's like a shark and a stingray
combined
there it is ugh
call Charlie Hunnam in the mech suits
where's the Pacific Rim team some
Yeagers in here we need the Yeagers
you know who we haven't seen in a while
at Shakespeare fellow oh no nah he's
back home writing news stories man
typing away I gotta come back couldn't
help foreshadowing there no no no no
suit to pay off
these two
[Music]
my hero oh no no Hawk man you did so
much [__] that's the price we pay for
dialogue this last moment of saving her
and never talking again
incarnate
promise me you won't give up on this on
life
oh on love Yeah remember
it's the only thing
worth living for
no
save him with true love's kiss
I'm coming
oh
oh buddy
time to go ham
mer unleash it Canary
yes oh no
no
crab monster
nice nice man
get it in the mouth Through The Eyes hey
come on it's like one of those video
game bosses yes
sorry
hey we
don't America
oh
yeah Steve
Dang
if you Bonk him hard enough on the head
keep bonking
cool oh
my face
you called that a scream
yes oh
peel flesh from bone
oh my God
she just skin that street shark
meanwhile in the crab fight a little
help over here
crap battle perfect
bowling
pretty tough on the outside
taking Pac-Man and then boom
oh my God it was so metal
so nth metal rest in peace yeah Steve
God
see Trevor's the coolest
no I admire your bravery but your fate
will be like the rest you have no
business fighting with gods
take it back oh you're about to get
junkie excelled dude yes
thank you
[Music]
once the key here
yeah no you you did this you should
yeah that's your dog I should probably
call him back
hey I'm sorry I didn't mean to yeah oh
foreign
just following orders it's all good it's
all good everybody you think this means
you've won you and your league Society
it's a society man the sound of failure
you're just a dude yeah man because he's
got psychic powers he's not just a dude
but he needs mcguffins and stuff he's
like the real Hitler he's not even as
great as his master wraith
no no what oh
damn it
[Music]
yes
you okay I'll be fine
uh
did he miss every major organ each
we have to do something we might not
have to look
there he is
Shakespeare
there he is does he have a mustache is
this the Justice League
he shaved
CGI shaved that's true yeah if you look
at his upper lip it's real distorted
[Music]
the Uber man
shaved
were you just a reporter I was am but I
couldn't sit on the sidelines any longer
I guess it was time to get in the game
Oh I thought when the war was over we
tomorrow is never guaranteed only today
that's why we fight right
so what do you say Diana Grant a dying
man his final request oh
no no no no no
oh
I wish I could stay but I've got a world
of my own that needs all the help I can
get
oh you understood why I said no I was
wrong oh
oh yeah
I had to give him a little push
wow
whoa
double flashes oh
damn
it's the moment he left in the oh that
was cool yeah Brainiac won't be the last
to show up and threaten our cities our
world but there are also others like us
if we stick together we can keep the
peace Fight For Truth the American way
hey they actually said it oh shoot I
forgot something glad some things
haven't changed
oh
I know we said that we could always have
tomorrow but whatever tomorrows I have I
want them to be with you Barry
what are you doing will you marry me yes
oh
just the right sizes Wonder Woman
[Music]
oh
cute that was lovely cute
and Chris was Superman Matt Boomer I
thought was flash it was Darren Chris
last time yeah Mercer is our man hell
yeah okay okay
Liam McIntyre was Aquaman so not a
slowed down nope someone else entirely
that's weird you're like let's just drop
fill in an octave yeah oh man I love
that I love that I at nope and it's such
linear writing but at no point did I
parallel the Steve Trevor Diana
relationship with his like that was the
whole point and I missed it which I love
yeah yeah no this had like this was so
rich and it had so many different
elements because like you know the World
War II threat is obviously very vital
and very sort of Snappy and engaged but
everybody's got a bit of a character
story there's romance to spare yeah and
like actual you know not just people
falling in love but you know like
there's a lot there's backstory there's
like weight yeah like the whole Steve
and Diana thing like was very Charming
but also came with like a heavy cost
and I'm curious actually because like
you know the the Wonder Woman portrayal
here is very much you know is is a war
Warrior woman yeah a little more stoic
has a bit more stoicism a bit more Stern
didn't bother me like it did in the uh
because she's not not that yeah but at
no point did she feel like she was a
warrior at the cost of her good and that
was my issue with the new 52 stuff was
yeah it felt like her being a warrior
was like a blunt object like where she
was like speed yeah whereas this is like
this this is what I have to do like like
one of the last things she said was like
you know when this is over I wanted to
see it like that felt like that good was
still there yeah she had to be a warrior
in times of War as opposed to the other
one where it was like throw me at stuff
I'm wrong let me add him let me yeah
like I don't like Scrappy do one Roman
yeah um so like this totally worked for
me because it was still her goodness and
even though it was accident like you
know it was times of War she was still
under there yeah absolutely and I mean I
thought she it was cool to see her
leading the team I thought she made like
a good I love the thing with Shakespeare
Superman and having to you know sort of
coax him in yeah and then the alternate
origin 2021 this is a reason so it was
well after the one room movie so well
yeah and I was wondering too during this
if they changed up her accent
specifically to sort of Harkin to Gal
Gadot and I'm guessing in the tomorrow
verse there is no Steve Trevor as he is
Canon Dead uh so they definitely did the
like you know time travel element but in
a different way but also it was a
different universe so I guess there
could be I guess yeah Wonder Woman what
I was wondering is that now I mean this
certainly seems like it's setting that
up and and we know from long Halloween
that that is pretty you know isolated on
its own so we've had a Batman long
Halloween we've had a Superman
introduction yeah and now we've got
Flash and Superman as a way to start the
Justice League yeah so I can imagine
whatever's next there will be like more
present day Justice and this was two
years ago so I imagine this is like the
universe as it is now like whatever
they're making currently I guess so or
or at least I don't know if the tomorrow
verse continues because they just
released a new movie recently it was
like something Batman Doom or something
like that yeah and then uh they've got
another crisis movie on the verge out
soon yeah uh I think they're doing
yeah yeah but I mean I'm just curious if
the tomorrow verse you know keeps going
or does it end before we get to the
present day because we're closer 2021
this wasn't long ago yeah I mean we've
got at least a couple more in this
continuity I think at minimum but uh
because the next one in Canon would have
been Batman
following this would be Batman okay so
now so it went flash it went Superman
Flash found in the Justice League but
Batman was was mentioned in Superman yes
and now we're going to meet Superman in
order and then whatever's next yeah me
Batman and then whatever's next
it's all going and especially for the
second installment to be like okay we're
jumping into an alternate dimension in
there yeah yeah that aren't going to
appear as they appeared here I thought
it was cool because uh you know sitting
here and having seen various recently
seen various takes on uh Barry going
back in time and changing things with
the speed force and all that stuff uh
like this was a really cool Twist on all
that that managed to hearken to those
without being oh we're doing another
flash point but it's in World War II
yeah it was a flash point but in a
totally different way and it allowed for
a Wonder Woman to be in the second film
without it being like the Wonder Woman
we might have yeah totally and it's like
I love that they had Barry as our sort
of eye line and I love that he fits into
the story whilst also sort of I don't
know still allowing like the rest of
this Justice Society to kind of have
that Spotlight like he's a really good
sort of comic relief he's a good eye
line for us and it's really fun to watch
him play off of Jay Garrick but also
like you know I feel like you still get
to have like the full brunt of just the
fun and excitement of seeing like the
Justice Society do their thing and yeah
and this particular team I thought was
really nice because it was cool to see
our man I've never seen him animated
yeah like our man uh uh Canary uh Pacman
speaks Hawkman speaks and even he like I
loved his little uh the moments between
him and uh Black Canary you know and and
her yeah that Bond there was interesting
yeah and that little subtle thing of
like maybe she'll take off you know she
in in a way that's never really is sort
of like obvious they sort of make her
out to be sort of like the most I did
like that of the team and so yeah by the
end it seems like she more fully
Embraces it despite the loss of the
moments of rudeness with strange and
like the also yeah that glance I really
liked I liked the use of of the invading
uh atlanteans like we've seen a few
times before but in this context it had
that like storming Normandy but storming
Santa Monica yeah yeah
yeah but it works for the story really
well yeah I mean it works in terms of
iconography because obviously blonde
hair blue eyed Arthur Curry but yeah but
that sure is Nazi yeah but then having
you know that little piece of of you
know almost Indiana jones-esque
historical fiction of like the Nazis are
always looking for these artifacts and
stuff and they're always looking for
like a cultish magical ways to help
their efforts and what do they do they
found the atlanteans and sort of
brainwashed their whole Fleet and the
torture elements were very much like
what we know of the horrors of the Nazis
and I like that like they might have
taken you know Dr Fate uh sorry
um no Dr Fate I said strange earlier and
I knew it was wrong and then I corrected
myself and it felt wrong twice I knew it
was fate don't don't at me uh but doctor
we gotta get you back to your right time
Coy what Universe am I in uh but Dr Fate
being someone that would have like an
artifact and like someone they would
torture for information like that all
felt very appropriate to the horrors of
what they built here yeah and uh you
know if if you saw my Superman video
there's a lot of Jewish iconography in
Superman because he was invented by a
pair of Jewish creators who were coping
with the horrors of the time and that's
why I've always liked the like Superman
versus the clan comic and like certain
elements of like you know him fight
Nazis is a lot like Captain America
fighting Nazis for me it feels like this
is the way it should be so him him
coming back then to take down all those
planes and stuff was like yeah yeah it
was a great and and like a lot of really
great like this also felt like a war
movie and it had multiple sequences that
hearken to different aspects of
different war movies you have your stuff
like out on you know these crumbling
European cities and things like that and
you're sort of no man's land type of you
know like grounded Warfare moments then
you have Naval like submarine and boat
battles then you have aerial battles and
then you get creatures and stuff like
that but this sort of ran the gamut of
all the different sort of
places we had to fight in the land in
the air of the sea and then you know
you're you're raiding this Castle which
has like a sort of Doom almost like wolf
and stuff like less you know crazy heavy
metal creatures or zombies but you know
it still has that sort of like
Wolfenstein exploitationy kind of feel
about it and uh and the action I thought
was the actual really so well shot so
well shot and captured and like
that yeah I know well I mean that's the
thing I mean like it it still is you're
still figuring out lighting they're
figuring out frames angles movement
blocking the camera like this was
forgive the pun but it was so Punchy and
it had so much energy and flavor yeah I
really think this was one of the more
specific ones they made choices and they
committed and they decided the theme and
the tone and they like engaged with the
audience the whole time and they still
did it while having all these characters
get their time in the sun it didn't feel
like the setting took over the
characters but it felt like they
adjusted the characters accordingly in a
way that was really on brand yeah I
really liked this one this was really
special this was a lot of fun yeah no I
loved the I loved the combination of
getting yeah all the range of heroism
and sci-fi that you want out of your DC
characters but also a truly committed
throwback to the World War II era hope
Constantine's in the tomorrow verse
because now at this point I love it
they've given us a really cool second
movie Swing so I'm really we don't know
what's coming so it's really exciting to
see like this is not something I would
expect as a second movie so I'm really
curious what the tomorrow verse becomes
yeah because that means they did a
Superman movie to launch a elseworld and
then a two harder Batman yeah what a
crazy journal what is the pacing let's
just go let's just do whatever
yeah so will I chase our wildest so far
I'm hitting I like yeah I mean I've
Loved uh this tomorrow verse Journey
thus far and I mean certainly the Batman
long Halloween's have their own batmany
kind of isolated quality they certainly
seem like they work on their own but
this especially the way this in those
brief uh prologue and epilogue moments
tied into the current timeline and and
Barry disappearing right before catching
the bullet coming back right behind him
so cool so great and and yeah like even
though
it I feel like it would have felt more
random if we were only in the past and
never had this little piece were really
nice yeah yeah that worked I I love this
especially as a Flashpoint story I like
I knew when we watched we started this
with Flashpoint I knew I liked
Flashpoint stories I did not know this
would be one and how much I'd love it so
I officially love Flashpoint stories
because that was a really special way to
tell that yeah I I loved kind of every
layer this was going for really yeah
good humor good personality good
everything and the specificity keep
making specific stuff if you've got
archetypal characters you make a
specific story because you've got the
trust of the audience in the characters
make more stuff like this DC this was
awesome come on let us know in the
comments uh I did not look this one up
to see if people loved it or hated it a
lot of times we watch these and
everybody's like well that was the worst
thing ever so uh it's really cool to see
like without knowing that like the the
people's opinion and then now I'm gonna
look up to people's opinion but uh let's
get a patron of the day shout out before
we Boogie on out of here we got
patron of the day shout out to Garth
McMurray this gentleman would you love a
Superman this gentleman must have loved
the Shakespearean twist this gentleman
must have quite enjoyed the way it was
handled and ended and I feel like
ardenberry also as an else World guy oh
sure uh so I feel like this was like uh
the right one I feel like this the right
Patron to shout out as we begin the
sales World Journey uh Garth we
appreciate your Justice your league your
society and your love the American way
uh much appreciated Arthur Murray as
ever because uh yeah this this feels
like your cup of tea so hopefully you've
seen this one hopefully you've seen us
talking about you here and if you
haven't seen this one you should go
watch this one yeah you shouldn't have
seen it without I mean it wouldn't have
made sense to watch us watch it pieces
hopefully I've seen it but we thank you
very much Garth McMurray you super sexy
reject much much appreciated you let us
know also what you want us to watch next
because yeah I've been I'm enjoying the
hell out of these much love y'all that
is going to do it for this episode of
John and koi watch stuff they've never
seen seen before and quite enjoy it yeah
tune in next time as we discover where
the tomorrow verse goes but I assume and
that what a swing so far I've been
digging it we'll see you soon much love
peace myself
[Music]